nature's going to put on quite a show
this weekend for sure look at this
glorious sunrise out there
this morning if you're making your toast
brushing your teeth if you have just a
second to take a look at the tv
it is so pretty most of views around the
valley are just socked in with clouds
but this one
just has that light just streaming in
between the holes and the clouds it is
so pretty out there
we have a lot of 60s it's been very mild
overnight we hit those mid to upper 80s
yesterday
we did have some high clouds they
weren't as thick and heavy in the
afternoon
set a new record high of 86. been very
mild though
and windy up in the mountains we've had
gusts now over 40 miles an hour
up there through the spring mountains
and we've got a wind advisory that will
start
later today i'll we'll show you that
wind advisory in just a minute
65 at red rock 64 in front very mild
you know where we were having
temperatures in the 40s low 50s
it's very different this morning with
the cloud cover keeping this mild and
it's all still over the desert southwest
the great basin
and it's going to combine with this
first system cold front is already
draped across northwest california
there's cold air with the first wave and
there's actually a second wave coming in
sunday so the first one will affect us
saturday with a chance of showers
and then reinforcing cold with a better
chance of mountain snow our
first mountain snow and first chance of
valley rain
the first chance of rain we've had in
over six months so we've got wind
advisories through the mountains nv
energy is talking about cutting the
power to about 500 customers up there
for the potential of you know just
saving the chance of fires pulling down
energy lines uh power lines up there
with these high winds
and then they've got oh and then also
the weather service has issued winter
storm watches
once we get to saturday night into
sunday night and early monday
we could see three to six inches of snow
above 5000 feet so this is going to be a
pretty powerful
couple of systems that move through and
cold 86 degrees for us today very very
warm but it's our last warm day
tomorrow we drop to the low 60s with a
small chance of showers that
second wave has more potential for
better rainfall in the valley
better snowfall in the mountains and we
drop to the 50s for highs
mornings in the 30s and we keep those
chilly 50s a day or two
only to about 61 sunshine on veterans
day